[Music]
power systems in anime is something that
makes the medium definitely stand out
from others
and along with a good power system comes
both powerful and impactful
transformations where one of the
characters move up in their respective
power hierarchy by transforming to a
more physically enhanced version of
themselves
and when this transformation is animated
in a mind-blowing way
it can even make a minor character a
potential side character
or even increase our impressions on the
main character today we're going to talk
about the top 10 most impactful naruto
transformations
and what's so good about them so let's
get started
at number 10 we have the eight tails
transformation of
killer bees
in the 143rd episode sasuke and his team
move on to capture killer bee
the holder of the eight tales when he
and sugetsu overpower him killer bee
decides to take a hasty retreat
and transform into the eight tales as
the eight tales he becomes an ushioni a
japanese folklore monster
with massive horns and tails of a squid
the reason why this transformation was
something epic wasn't because of the way
he transformed
but because of our amazement to witness
a tailed beast and its power with killer
bee being the eight tails
cards were reversed and sasuke and his
team found a more harder challenge
facing him not to mention his tailed
beast ball which was one of the most
powerful chakra attacks seen in the
series to that day
killer b managed to show us what the
power of a truly transformed tailed
beast looks like
[Music]
at number nine comes the transformation
of kabuto we're talking about a man who
followed orochimaru so you shouldn't
expect anything less
kabuto was a villain for most of the
series but his transformation during the
battle with sasuke and itachi was where
his power levels were at the peak
as the two brothers find him in the
caves his face is more deformed and has
a look similar to orichimaru
this transformation gives the chance for
kabuto to use several of his research
techniques
such as tsugetsu hazuki's hydrification
technique
and even his own sage mode a state
origimaru was never able to achieve
the meaning of this transformation was
to thematically show how kabuto had
moved out of urichimaru's shadow and is
making his own identity
and his final form also resembled the
research he'd done on all the different
techniques and transformations of other
people
without doubt the two uchiha brothers
had some trouble facing them
because both of them had their own
confrontations to handle
next up at number eight we have the
transformation of obito
obito uchia is one of those characters
we loved
and hated we hated him when he was a
masked villain disguised as madara but
we sympathized with him as we learned
his backstory with kakashi and rin
but in the climax of the fourth shinobi
war obito does something that he can't
turn back from he traps the ten tails
from within his own body
as he traps his jin turiki his previous
wounds are healed and he receives
enhanced speed and agility
and becomes nearly impervious to any
sort of damage another thing here is
that with this transformation
he received a far greater power than the
original ten tails itself
because he had more concentration than
the tailed beast and had the ability to
focus on the large amounts of chakra it
was releasing
with this he even managed to control the
ten tails tree and performed the
infinite tsukuyomi
which showed how much dedication he had
for his goal and the hidden potential
behind his character
at number seven we get the
transformation of sasuke no we're not
talking about his transformation in the
original series
nor his later transformations in the
beginning or during the climax of the
fourth shinobi war
but his very final form the final susano
which was the most powerful form that
merged the chakra of all the tailed
beasts
along with sasuke's own part of the
reason why this transformation was very
impactful
was because like obito sasuke showed how
much he was willing to give
in order to achieve his goals and on the
other hand this revealed that this young
shinobi was one of the strongest to
exist at that time
and the only one who could stand toe to
toe in a fight with naruto
this version of sasuke susano has a
powerful sabre sword
and a pair of katana along with a bow
[Music]
number six is naruto's transformation to
his biju mode
we can't just leave off with sasuke
susano without mentioning the very ninja
he battled against
naruto's biju mode or the very last
gurama combination in his arsenal
is the most powerful naruto
transformation that's only
second to sasuke susano naruto undergoes
this transformation when he perfectly
syncs with gurama's chakra and its most
powerful form
the ashura kurama mode is naruto's power
level at its peak
this is completely made from chakra and
resembles ashura utsutsuki's chakra
avatar
in this transformation naruto can create
his own
shadow clones and unleash his most
powerful attack the six paths
ultra big ball russ and shuriken this
form stood toe to toe with sasuke sosano
and the attacks of the two managed to
nearly shatter valley of end
this transformation also reflected how
much naruto has grown as a character on
a physical level
and a mental level from the screaming
blonde ninja we saw
in episode one
coming in at number five we have
naruto's nine tail cloak transformation
going along the same topic we have to
time travel a bit back to the original
series
when naruto and sasuke first fight in
the valley of end
we see him tap to the very first form of
the jin churiki
this is what jiraiya later calls the
demon fox cloak or the nine tail cloak
where a shroud of translucent red bubble
chakra surrounds naruto
this gives him enhanced strength and
protection but using too much will hurt
his own body
i think the reason why this
transformation was so impactful is
purely obvious
we witnessed naruto using the strength
of the tailed beast inside him
but that isn't the main factor in this
fight naruto reached far more damage
from sasuke in both physical and
emotional levels
he was being attacked by the person he
called his best friend and
he was struggling more than anyone to
rescue sasuke from the part he was
traveling on
so this transformation is a repercussion
of both his emotional
and battle scars
next up on this list we have madras
transformation
we can't compile this list without
mentioning madara the man who was the
beginning to
everything in his normal resurrected
form he summoned meteorites but when he
combined
powers with the ten tails he managed to
successfully seal the beast inside him
and gain complete control over the
jinchuriki this transformation was even
more powerful than obito's own
and gave madala a great amount of
dexterity and defense in terms of a
ninja
he managed to dodge powerful attacks
such as the flying thunder god technique
and gamui
and even managed to barely survive night
guy even though he dealt him heavy
damage
this also gave him the ability to use
the true seeking balls which were a
combination of
yin yang chakra that were highly
malleable to cast off great attacks
and even make powerful ninjutsu
worthless against madara this form's
most powerful and dangerous attack was
the ability to cast
infinite tsukuyomi and even use nature
energy
the reason why this is so impactful is
because this
is when we saw the peak of madrasia
[Music]
coming in at number three is rock lee's
reverse lotus transformation
we're probably introduced to this
optimistic energetic and hot-blooded
ninja back in the tuning exam arc
and it was this very arc that he showed
his potential in the preliminaries he
was matched with gara
the monster of the sand village and when
the battle reached its climax and things
were desperate
rock lee's mentor might guy allowed him
to use the reverse lotus transformation
this transformation happens when the
user opens at least three of the eight
gates and gains enhanced speed and
agility
with lee using the reverse lotus he was
able to easily overpower gara's shield
of sand without
any problems at all my guy taught this
to lead to use as a last resort
because this gives the user both the
advantage and disadvantage the
disadvantage is that it leaves the body
of the user completely damaged
and sometimes even unable to move so if
your opponent happens to still survive
the battle just like in gara's case
he suddenly gains the upper hand but
ignoring its weakness
we have to add this to our list because
this transformation is what brought the
king of sand to his knees
we're now going to move on to the most
popular and perhaps the most debated arc
in the shippuden series the pain arc
some may call it one of the best
directed episodes in anime
and others may call it an episode with
potential hindered by the animation but
either way one of the things that both
parties agree on was the impactful
transformation of naruto it's the third
time
naruto transformed to one of his tailed
beast modes and this was one of the
fiercest transformations of him seen up
to date there was pure rage and hatred
boiling within naruto for the death of
jirayah sensei and pain attacking hinata
was the last drop needed to make it
explode the form of naruto represented a
deeper part of his hatred he didn't want
to reveal
and also the power of the jin churiki
hiding within him and even if you don't
call those attacks impactful
i'm pretty sure payne will
topping our list at number one we have
might guys eight
gates transformation you saw what
rockley did with three gates
open so imagine a more grown and capable
ninja opening all the eight gates
yes we're talking about none other than
the transformation of
might guide just as he taught lee
opening the gates did put a heavy toll
on him
but during the fourth ninja war he was
able to open up to seven
gates multiple times that his body got
used to but
the opening of that final gate required
much more concentration and physical
pain
and the results were enough to bring mad
nearly to his death
with each gate he opened guy received
several enhanced attacks
such as the front lotus reverse lotus
morning peacock daytime tiger and
finally
the night guy a single kick that can
distort the space around it just because
of its power
the sheer animation combined with mike
guy's epic actions and voice
made this not only one of the most
impactful naruto transformations
but also one of the best anime
transformations
up to date so which transformation do
you think was epic was it one of
naruto's jinchuriki modes born by pure
rage and anger
or is it perhaps the transformation of
madara or might guy which showed how
much these characters had stored within
them let us know in the comments below
and if you want to see more content like
this
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
and hit the notification bell for
updates
i'll see you next time on vini tube
[Music]
you